a Ukrainian plane carrying a hundred and
seventy six people has crashed shortly
after taking off from the Iranian
capital of Tehran Iranian state
television says everyone on board has
died in the last hour Ukrainian
international airline said it was
suspending flights to Tehran
indefinitely and that the plane passed
its last technical service two days ago
a radar of the plane shows it's like
ending shortly after taking off from the
Imam Khomeini International Airport and
let's get more information should we our
correspondent asked our correspondent
ever virtually is with me here in the
studio all souls lost yes and we're
getting more detail about who was on
board so we knew that it was a hundred
and sixty-seven passengers and nine crew
members and we understand now we're
being told from the Ukrainian minister
of foreign affairs that actually three
of those people according to reports
were British nationals 82 from Iran 63
people were Canadian and 11 Ukrainians -
a nine of whom were made up that crew
now the reports are that this was some
form of catastrophic mechanical failure
but what we have heard now from
Ukrainian international airlines is that
just two days ago this aircraft this
Boeing 737-800 actually passed its
Technical Service the Ukrainian embassy
has also said in Iran that this was not
terrorism related they've talked about
an engine failure and it's also backed
up by an Iranian government official who
says that there was an engine fire that
a pilot the pilot lost control which
brought this aircraft down thankfully in
a field to the southwest of Tehran and
there are some reports that is possible
the pilot may have steered the aircraft
away from residential areas obviously we
need to get confirmation of that first
but no survivors the emergency services
had gone there hoping to find survivors
but the ferocity of the fire meant that
that wasn't the case so now they have
begun their investigation they've begun
the gruesome good job of recovering
bodies and
the airline itself has said that they
are carrying out a thorough
investigation with support from all
sides as you would expect they're
contacting relatives and providing
support for them and that airlines
saying that they've suspended all
flights to tier on indefinitely and we
are actually getting a little bit more
detail now about who was onboard so as
well as the three British nationals
we're told the Iranians and Canadians
and Ukrainians we've got four people
from Afghanistan three German passengers
ten who were Swedish and then of course
those three British passing passengers
extraordinary timing of course just
hours after the missile attacks on those
bases in Iraq with the Ukraine with the
US and coalition forces however we are
told that this was mechanical one of the
black boxes has been recovered so
hopefully that will provide more answers